well I started out as a lawyer I mean I
was sort of what I wanted to do and was
very fortunate early on had a clerkship
on the Supreme Court the with Lewis
Powell who affected the way I think
about public service my career and
basically after a number of years in
private sector I was asked by President
Clinton to be his deputy counsel and
then from there went to the Antitrust
Division is justice department and that
really had a profound impact on me in
terms of public service and in terms of
government and in terms of bureaucracy
in thinking about how do you make
bureaucracies much much more effective
managed well and so forth and when I
left at the end of the Clinton
administration I decided that my career
would be at the intersection of media
and technology not too similar to where
you're putting your career these days
and i went to Bertelsmann the german
media company and i was basically
running the corporate aspects for the in
the united states for thomas middle half
and was in the middle of all of that
that the mayor got elected Mike
Bloomberg and he asked me whether I'd
like to be considered for a Chancellor I
had done a fair amount of work in the
district of columbia in fact was
thinking of going on the school board
when Mayor Anthony Williams got some
appointments there and I was part of a
group that was kind of advising Tony
Williams and you know given my
background on my passion about education
and my sense that education is not
working well particularly for poor kids
in the United States when the mayor
asked me after he had just gotten
control from the legislature in Albany I
decided this is where my heart and
whatever talents i have should be and
it's been almost six years now
well I had a meager background but yes
he did have to apply for an exemption I
think for me what I think is that
fundamentally the system is a service
delivery system and its broken its
incentives are misaligned it's managed
poorly it basically tolerates mediocrity
rewards failure and I think if you're a
change agent and some of the very same
principles applied in the Justice
Department if you're fundamentally a
transformative leader which I've
considered myself to be I thought this
was as important an opportunity and
quite frankly an opportunity I trained
for for much of my adult life I mean I
believe so deeply that education is the
great leveler and if you get that wrong
and almost a rosy and sense you get the
preconditions to what it means to grow
up in America you get those wrong and so
I I had a sense that this was going to
take a systems transformation it's
always hard to speak for the mayor on
what motivated him but I suppose a
combination of his sense that somebody
who was outside the system wasn't
beholden to the structures that existed
the players that existed somebody who
had a fair amount of managerial
experience which i had in the Justice
Department Anna bertelsmann and somebody
i hope this matter to him had my passion
for making sure that education was
equitable and that whether you were rich
or poor black oh why you got a fair shot
at the American dream something that's
not happening in our country and I hope
those are the things that resonated with
the mayor